one of the most surprising aspects about
one of the saddest of all human
possibilities is that the suicide rate
goes up markedly the richer and more
developed a society becomes we might
expect suicide rates to vary across time
and place but not to increase alongside
developments in wealth comfort and
security that we should be unwittingly
creating nations in which more of us end
up killing ourselves at our own hands
appears to negate the whole purpose of
economic growth nevertheless the
disturbing connection between suicide
and an increase in development and
wealth was first conclusively identified
towards the end of the 19th century by
the leading French sociologist Emile
Durkheim and it's continued to be noted
ever since the suicide rate of an
undeveloped country like the Democratic
Republic of the Congo is a fraction of
the rate of a developed nation like
South Korea the crucial factor behind
people's decision to end their lives is
not really wealth or poverty as Emile
Durkheim discovered it's the extent to
which the surrounding culture ascribes
responsibility for failure to
individuals or else maintains a faith
that poor lack or divine interventions
are to blame for failure instead it so
happens that as societies become modern
and industrialized they very frequently
give up their beliefs in demons and gods
and start instead to trust in a
meritocratic individualistic philosophy
that suggests to people that their fate
is always in their own hands this may
sound generous but it carries an immense
psychological burden because it means
that when failure does occur the
individual is held entirely responsible
for it any reversals start to seem like
a horrendous judgment on one's Worth and
value and a public humiliation from
which there may at the extreme seem no
escape other than through self
annihilation there are two big cultural
ideas that may help to mitigate the
pressures upon us
luck and tragedy to believe in luck is
accurately to observe that merit and
success are in fact never reliably
aligned one can be a fool and win or a
virtuous person and fail if we fully
internalize and widely share the notion
of luck then the shame of failure will
be greatly reduced in our agony along
with it we will be able to admit
publicly and to ourselves that decent
people can fail in their outward
circumstances and therefore the
professional success isn't the only or
even the crucial marker of the merit of
human beings a tragedy as it originated
in ancient Greece is the story of a
capable and intelligent person who
happens to make a small mistake which
however leads to appalling consequences
the point of presenting such stories in
very public ways at Greek festivals the
entire community had to attend was to
continually renew acquaintance with a
hugely important idea that one can be a
likable even admirable person and end up
in an utterly desperate situation
tragedy is the careful telling of how
disaster can come into the lives of
people like or even a bit nicer than us
they and hence we are always deserving
of compassion rather than contempt emile
durkheim knew that it's not prosperity
by itself that increases the suicide
rate the toxic element is an unwittingly
cruel culture that assigns a high burden
of responsibility to us while seeming to
deny the truth that chance and tragedy
will of course always continue to affect
our destinies the real solution to a
high suicide rate therefore lies in an
unexpected place an ideology that firmly
reminds us that we are never the sole
authors of our destinies and should
therefore neither simply panic nor
celebrate when we win or lose
we publish new thought-provoking films
every week be sure to subscribe to our
Channel and take a look at more of what
we have to offer at the link on your
screen now